Vichy Island et Magnus Carson ont
disputé une finale extraordinaire lors
de la globale qui est une compétition
rapide qui se déroule devant un vrai
échiquier l'analyse vaut vraiment le
détour elle est hyper instructive et
spectaculaire les deux hommes ont
l'habitude de s'affronter parce qu'ils
sont déjà rencontrés pour le titre
mondial à deux reprises ça rappelle des
très bons souvenirs à ce qu'il avait
emporté à chaque fois mais ici le jeu
est moindre pourtant on va avoir le
droit vraiment à des finesses exquises
alors on va commencer avec cette
position on est au 60e coup car un scène
a les pièces noires Annona donc les
blancs il y a déjà une grosse bataille
et la première chose qu'on remarque
c'est une égalité matérielle mais par
contre il y a un fou contre un cavalier
et la première vue ce fou de casse
blanche a l'air de complètement dominer
le cavalier on voit que le Cavalier
Blanc a beaucoup de mal à trouver des
cases pour s'exprimer mais la position
des blanches est un petit peu compensée
par ce pion à passer qui a une case de
la dame pour l'instant contrôlé par le
fou alors quel est le plan des Noirs
dans cette position c'est de jouer B4
puisque clairement de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier on est bloqué et donc il
faut se créer un pion passé le long de
la colonne C B4 l'idée c'est dévier le
pion des blancs et derrière on envoie
notre pion c'est une fusée il est
escorté parfaitement par nos trois
contrôle toutes les cassettes pour aller
faire une nouvelle dame donc ici ah non
il devait faire face à ce problème et il
a décidé de jouer cavalier prend F5
s'avère être une erreur il a sacrifié
son cavalier il a calculé une ligne
extrêmement profonde vous allez voir
tout à l'heure on va y revenir juste
voilà son idée première c'est de se
créer un second qui ont passé afin de
jouer E6 dans la foulée en disant bah le
fou hein il est surchargé il va pas
pouvoir arrêter les deux pions à la fois
mais car scène ici va avoir du contrôle
B4 on va y revenir on va essayer de
comprendre quelle était la bonne façon
de faire nul pour un onde dans cette
position il fallait en réalité jouer
cavalier F1 échec donc un peu
contre-intuitif et on pouvait créer une
espèce de statu quo le but est de
chasser le roi de cette case où il
contrôle on a vu que c'était très
important la promotion de spion C qui
est l'arme ultime des Noirs dans cette
position donc on va regarder ce qui se
passe si le roi recule en Détroit on
revient en G3 avec le cavalier et on dit
au noir bah à toi de jouer comment tu
progresses en fait on va commencer par
le coup critique donc jouer BK4 les
blancs prennent le pion on joue C3
échecs mais le problème c'est que
maintenant le roi blanc peut se mettre
sur la case d'arrivée du pion c'est une
case noir donc ça c'est hyper instructif
il y a un fou de casse blanche on a un
roi ça veut dire que ce roi il est
indéniable on a aucune pièce pour le
chasser donc notre pion c'est finalement
il est bloqué complètement et la roue à
s'inverse totalement ce sont les blancs
maintenant qui vont être gagnants parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup trop de pions ils
ont la même idée que dans la partie
sacrifier leur cavalier et ensuite ils
vont envoyer le Pione le pion a le pion
B et le fou noir il a pas pouvoir tout
arrêter donc ceci ne fonctionne pas pour
les blancs alors pourquoi pas jouer ici
à la place de ces trois échecs croient
des deux pour menacer de nouveau
utiliser ce Cortez notre pion et ben
comme tout à l'heure le cavalier va
revenir à nouveau faire échec et si le
roi noir tente de se mettre en D1 alors
là c'est la catastrophique qui aurait
même une fourchette cavalier 3 derrière
on mange le four et notre plus on va
aller tout simplement à dames donc ça
évidemment ça a pas été envisé par
Cassen et s'il recule ben on répète
encore une fois la position on a donc ce
statu quo la dernière la petite astuce à
comprendre d'ici afin de devoir pourquoi
la partie est nulle et pourquoi les
Noirs ne peut pas progresser c'est que
si donc on a vu que B4 marchait pas il
tente de ramener leur roi ce qui a l'air
naturel pour aller manger les pions de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier alors
maintenant cavalier.5 échec va devenir
très fort et même gagnant puisque quelle
est la différence cette fois ci c'est
que le roi est une case plus loin pour
aller escorter spion et c'est genre de
finale ça joue toujours autant près sont
des courses entre les deux camps le
premier qui va Adam et perdre un temps
généralement c'est décisives alors on va
aller jusqu'au bout de la variante pour
bien que vous compreniez on avance le
pion aussi le fou peut pas le manger
sinon on sur le champ les noirs doivent
ramener leur roi en D2 on avance le pion
E7 on joue bécatrice pour essayer de se
créer espion passé mais on est trop en
retard E8 dame les Noirs prennent le
pion sur échec où on bouge la 3 et on
voit que le pion est à une case de la
dame qui manque un temps au noir pour
faire marcher cette variante là c'est au
blanc de jouer pour terminer alors c'est
dur d'empêcher spion d'aller à dame mais
on pourrait peut-être gagner en me
faisant une deuxième dame par exemple en
mettant notre Dame ici on coule fou donc
on laisse les Noirs faire dames on va
manger le fou sur échec et derrière il
faudra quand même faire un peu attention
aux réseaux sur notre roi mais on peut
faire plein d'échecs et au moment
important on fera une deuxième dame elle
est dedans contre une ça gagnera
facilement donc pour toutes ces raisons
qui sont quand même déjà assez subtil
avec cavalier F1 aurait permis à un
nombre de sauver le demi point mais on
va s'intéresser à la partie il a joué
cavalier prend F5 bon pas le choix car
ça ne mange le Caval là évidemment on
avance notre pion on peut pas perdre de
temps aussi les Noirs envoient contre
jeu avec B4 donc on se retrouve à
nouveau dans une course de pions E7 donc
tout ça c'était bien sur Calculer par un
angle puis on prend ces trois échecs là
attention on met le roi dans ce genre de
position évidemment on va éviter de se
mettre sur une case ou le pion adverse
va faire dames sur échec ce serait
catastrophique donc la case logique
c'est roi A2 et ici encore à un moment
critique très pointu après ces deux car
cette nuit il a pas le choix c'est que
on a deux possibilités de faire dames et
finalement ce qui est plutôt intuitif
c'est à dire mettre notre Dame en E8
puisque le fou contrôle cette casse
perdrait sur le champ pourquoi parce que
sur promotion alors les noirs peuvent
faire un échec à la découverte et le roi
des blancs est obligé d'aller se mettre
sur une des mauvaises cases par exemple
en A3 et derrière on fait dames sur
échec donc les Noirs ici maintenant un
food plus et ils ont la main surtout
c'est eux qui vont pouvoir enchaîner les
échecs ils contrôlent la case il y a pas
de danger donc ici c'est perdu mais
évidemment à Nantes il est pas né de la
dernière pluie il avait vu tout ça en
amont
et dans cette position il a fait à huit
dames donc comme un très joli coup son
but est de dévier le fou donc là on a
pas le choix avec les avec les noirs on
va pas faire dames sinon on s'est
bouffer notre fou sur échec donc on
mange la Dame Blanche
maintenant on fait vite dame et la
nuance c'est que il y a plus ce foulard
pour faire pour faire une découverte et
donc dans cette position les blancs
peuvent reprendre la main et ça va être
de jouer faire échec et tout ça on est
sur canon il a tout calculé et en fait
faire dame avec le noir ce serait une
erreur et c'est là où la finale est
vraiment extraordinaire ça permettrait
un match nul sur le champ avec une dame
folle donc un onde avait prévu ici
certainement de jouer dame 3 échec et on
se rend compte que si les Noirs mangent
la dame et ben c'est pâtes le roi blanc
vous voyez il a aucune case les pions
sont bloqués et donc on fait un nul
quand même assez cocasse ici
si le roi noir tente de fuir que ce soit
en D1 on fait dame de échec on va pas
lui laisser le choix que de manger
Notre-Dame de nouveau ça fait pâte et
pareil s'il va en C2 encore une fois on
va avoir un pack peu importe comment il
prend dans tous les cas le roi blanc
reste dans sa cage et il y a aucun coût
légal donc c'était un sauvetage quand
même incroyable il faut bien penser que
à Nantes tout ça il a calculé à partir
de notre position de base donc déjà
c'est une sacrée ligne
de beaucoup de coups avec moins d'une
minute à la pendule donc ça vous donne
une idée de la vitesse et de la
profondeur de calcul des joueurs de ce
niveau à Nandin qui a dépassé les 50 ans
mais on voit qu'il est encore un joueur
vraiment vraiment incroyable
malheureusement pour le tigre de Madras
il est en face de lui peut-être le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps donc
évidemment il s'est rendu compte de la
supercherie d'ailleurs à ce moment c'est
assez rigolo les deux joueurs ont
échangé un petit rire un petit sourire
devant l'intensité la position et la
tourner possible ils ont bien réalisé
cette idée de
et Carsen a voulu à tout prix jouer pour
le gain il a joué foot4 qui est un coup
très humain mais qui ne s'avère pas être
le coup gagnant l'idée c'est vraiment de
bloquer cette dame et de pouvoir faire
ensuite promotion dans de meilleures
conditions quelques coups plus tard le
coup gagnant était extrêmement fin
quasiment introuvable avec si peu de
temps à la pendule il fallait jouer C3
et l'idée en fait c'est de donner une
case de fuite au roi blanc on libère la
case la case B3 et donc désormais dans
toutes les idées de dames qui vont venir
ensuite alimenter la position il n'y
aura plus de pâte voilà le but c'est
vraiment de donner une case de fuite au
roi blanc alors on va voir pourquoi ça
gagne ici on pourrait penser que les
blancs vont parvenir à harceler le roi
noir d'échec mais en réalité il va
toujours trouver une cachette commençons
par Dame des cette échec le roi va en E1
nouvelle échec histoire d'aller
s'infiltrer allèle roi sur casse noire
le Fou vient faire bouclier damage cat
échec roi D1 et cette fois-ci les blancs
reste plus qu'un seul échec à
disposition ou à que la géométrie est
assez merveilleuse puisque toutes les
cases pour s'infiltrer sont contrôler la
dame doit faire machine arrière en D8 et
après Road 2 cette fois-ci les échecs
sont terminés et le coup d'après les
Noirs vont pouvoir à obtenir une
nouvelle date l'autre option envisagée
dans cette position au lieu de faire des
échecs ça aurait été de manger le fou
mais ici la finale de dame est gagnante
pour les Noirs assez facilement même si
les blancs peuvent faire quelques échecs
à terme le roi va réussir à se cacher on
va manger les pions il y a trop de pions
de plus et on va réussir soit ramener
notre Dame en défense pour bloquer soit
faire un compte échec échanger les dames
et avoir une salle de roi Gayant ici
c'est vraiment sans espoir donc tout
gagné pour les Noirs si gardien avait
trouvé cette subtilité incroyable au
lieu de quoi retour à la partie donc
avec ce coup faux E4 qui est quand même
très logique et qui pose de gros
problèmes pratiques un an à jouer dame
de 8 échec logique le Fou vient à
nouveau se mettre devant en bouclier et
maintenant les blancs doivent trouver
une défense pour se prémunir de cette
menace encore une fois de promotion ici
d'exister un coup miraculeux un an à
trouver encore une fois l'idée mais il a
mal exécuté la nuance était très dur à
comprendre on va avoir il a joué dame
descart très naturelle qui centralise sa
dame et son piège était diabolique
puisque si quand ça ne faisait dames une
nouvelle fois il y avait ce fameux thème
de pâtes on sacrifiant la dame en
faisant une dame folle dame 3 échec et
si le roi vient manger la dame regardez
une nouvelle fois le roi blanc n'a
aucune case il y a aucun coût légal
c'est donc pâte et si le roi noir tente
de fuir par exemple en C2 on peut faire
dames prendre des trois et c'est comme
tout à l'heure ça va encore faire patte
peu importe la façon dont on reprend le
pion si le roi avance et 3 on peut faire
un espèce d'échec perpétuel très rigolo
en mettant notre Dame en prise à chaque
fois et elle est tout le temps
imprenable si on veut forcer le roi à
capturer la dame on a cette variante
illustrative et on termine une indienne
fois par un patte très rigolo qui aurait
été une jolie une jolie fin de partie
mais bien évidemment un carcène il s'est
rendu compte de tout ça et il a joué
l'incroyable promotion cavalier échec
qui est le seul coup gagnant dans la
position l'idée du numéro mondial c'est
de se dire que ces trois pièces vont
escorter son pion jusqu'à dames il va
réussir à chaque fois à créer des
boucliers pour empêcher les échecs
perpétuels et il a totalement raison
puisque maintenant la position est
gagnante pour les noirs on va voir quand
même comment un an des de se défendre il
a enlevé son roi pas le choix de l'échec
le pion avance la dame vient revenir en
B6 afin d'essayer de manger Hashi c'est
de trouver du contre jeu
cavalier 2 dam prend HS C2 et la hanoda
abandonné puisque finalement ça se joue
encore une fois un temps près on se rend
compte que si la dame revient pour
essayer de se sacrifier et de promouvoir
le pion h il va manquer donc un petit
temps au blanc pour s'en sortir donc on
va regarder ce que ça va donner dans mes
chèques dame prend on prend avec le roi
très important puisque c'est notre
cavalier qui va revenir roi apprend pion
H6 cavalier prend puis on achète et in
extremis le cavalier qui vient contrôler
la case de promotion et derrière c'est
le pion F qui va nous offrir la victoire
alors cette année ils avaient pas fini
puisque c'était important de voir
d'abord cette variante de gains pour
comprendre comment un nom aurait pu
sauver la partie donc petit retour en
arrière on avait donc cette position
vous rappelez ou un nom d'ajouter dame
Descat et car ça n'a fait promotion
cavalier quel était le seul coup miracle
pour s'en sortir avec les Blancs c'était
dame B6 il faut vraiment avoir un
cerveau de super ordinateur pour
comprendre tout ça quelques secondes et
donc sur ces undam c'est toujours la
même histoire les fameux
perpétuels et sacrifices de dames pour
faire des pâtes et des dames folles donc
là il y a toujours la même chose à
chaque fois qu'on prend la dame ça fait
pâte et le l'alliance par contre
beaucoup plus subtile c'est que sur
cavalier échec donc trois bouges jusqu'à
là on a l'impression que c'est comme
tout à l'heure sauf que les Blancs ont
un temps d'avance par rapport à tout à
l'heure puisque là ils peuvent manger le
pion HS directement et vous allez voir
que ça fait toute la différence la dame
revient le cavalier bouge le pion pousse
et cette fois-ci regardez le pion blanc
va Adam et cette fois sont même les
blancs qui peuvent espérer gagner alors
cette finale elle est censée être nulle
théorique avec fou cavalier pion contre
dames mais en tout cas en pratique les
blancs peuvent un peu essayer et puis
surtout ils ont évité le pire ils ont
évité la défaite donc il aurait fallu
que un nombre comprenne cette énième
subtilité pour s'en sortir la dernière
ligne intéressante à regarder dans la
partie donc après dame D4 promotion
cavalier chèque roi bouge C3 c'est si au
lieu d'aller manger donc ce pion on a vu
qu'il manque un temps en blanc pour que
ça marche ah non avait essayé d'empêcher
finalement un pion c'est parce qu'on se
dit bon il est pas encore Adam pourquoi
ne pas par exemple le cloué par dame B4
l'empêcher d'avancer petit à petit en
fait les pièces noires ont réussi à se
mettre en action à s'organiser et la
dame serait retrouvée impuissante on va
avoir une variante illustrative donc
cavalier E2 on ramène le cavalier pour
libérer le champ libre au pion le roi
blanc tente de prêter main forte à Sa
Majesté la Reine oh non on va aller
cacher nos trois pour essayer de
s'enlever des échecs et puis à terme il
va falloir se déclaer pour l'instant on
peut pas pousser par exemple damassin
qu'avec les blancs on dit ok je
maintiens le courage je vais peut-être
essayer de te faire des échecs sur le
côté donc notre 300 lève
et là on va voir à chaque fois il y a
souvent qu'un échec ou de maximum pour
les blancs échec Roy F2 à tout ceci
n'est pas forcé mais ça illustre la
difficulté qu'on les blancs à trouver
des ressources encore un échec roi F3
un dernier petit échec en à 8 et après
foue 4 cette fois-ci le débat éclos la
dame ne peut plus rien faire et les
coups d'après c'est C2 et c'est un dames
la dame va devoir se sacrifier sur le
pion et puis les Noirs resteront avec un
avantage matériel colossal donc les
pièces mineures ici on la part belle sur
la Dame Blanche voilà pour l'analyse de
cette finale quand même extrêmement
pointu avec des ressources des
rebondissements et des fait tactiques un
peu dans tous les sens j'espère que ça
vous a plu vous avez bien compris les
subtilités n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit commentaire si c'est le cas c'est
des questions des remarques et je vous
dis à bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]